[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
SVD and how you can decompose large high
dimensional data sets represented in a
matrix X into a few dominant columns and
rows stored in the matrices U and V so
this gives us a principled approach to
dimensionality reduction of high
dimensional data sets and it's one of
the first tools in our arsenal of
dimensionality reduction statistical
analysis of high dimensional data sets
and machine learning okay so what I'm
going to talk about now is one of my
favorite topics in dimensionality
reduction and the SVD and that's the
eigenfaces example so I'm gonna walk you
through in MATLAB how to take a matrix
where the columns are examples of human
faces pictures of human faces reshaped
into tall skinny vectors and I'm going
to show you how you can use the SVD to
get this eigenfaces representation
that's really useful for classification
and analysis okay so we're gonna use the
Yale B data set it's a really really
cool data set where if you look here on
the right panel there is this geodesic
dome with different lights and a camera
facing an individual and within a short
period of time about two seconds all of
these camera these lights would flash at
different angles and a bunch of pictures
will be taken of the person front on and
so you can see that for this individual
there's all of these different photos I
think it's 64 photos from different
lighting conditions so one half of their
face is shadowed the other half of their
face is shadowed above and below left
and right and so on and so forth and in
addition there are a large number of
individuals in the 30s or 40s of
individuals that have each had their
face picture taken at all of these
different lighting conditions okay so
it's a really big data set the Yale B
data set and we're going to use this to
demonstrate how the SVD can give
interpretable eigenfaces to represent
these these facial images now you can
also do this on what's known as the
eigen pets so if you have a bunch of
images of cats and dogs you can
similarly use the SVD
to find your eigen pets but I'm really
gonna focus on on the eigen faces in the
Yale database today okay
just again to point out this is all all
of the code and data is our website data
book u-dub comm this is following
chapter 1 section 6 of the book
data-driven science and engineering ok
good so the first thing we're gonna do
in MATLAB is load all of the data so I'm
gonna break this one up into a few
different videos because it'll it'll be
too long if I if I have them all
separately so in this video all we're
gonna do is we're going to load all of
the images in that Yale database and
then in the next video we're going to
compute the SVD and analyze the
eigenfaces look at how they can be used
for reconstruction and so on and so
forth ok so here at databook u-dub comm
there is a data type file that has all
of the data for all the examples in the
book and here we're just gonna load this
matrix all faces dot mat ok this is a
big big matrix where all of the
individuals faces have been rearranged
as tall skinny column vectors in this
massive data matrix so I'm gonna load it
I'm gonna plot it and I'm gonna walk you
through how the data is structured ok
maybe the first thing I'll do is I'll
just load the data ok good now I have
this matrix called faces and if I just
do size of faces you're gonna see that
this is a very very large matrix so
there are two thousand four hundred and
ten individual pictures of human faces
and each of those those those pictures
has been reshaped into a very tall
32,000 by one column vector okay so the
dimension of an actual picture I think
is 168 pixels by 192 pixels and if you
multiply that out you get this 32 256 by
1 column vector okay so every person has
a bunch of images at different lighting
conditions and then I have a bunch of
individual people and that's how this is
arranged so the first column is the
first picture of person 1 the
second column is the second person the
second picture of person one the third
picture of person one and so forth so
the first block is just person one then
there's a block for person to a block
for person three and so on and so forth
and it looks like there are 38 persons
so there are 38 people in this in this
matrix faces okay so the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to create this
big array of all persons I just want to
plot all of the different people that
we're going to use for this model and
I'm only gonna train my SVD I'm only
gonna learn the eigenfaces using the
first 36 people's faces and we're gonna
see if those eigen faces which are going
to be stored in the columns of U can be
used to represent another person's face
that was not in the training dataset
person 37 so I'm only gonna show you the
first 36 people we're only gonna use
them to train the model and then we're
gonna see if that model still works for
person 37 okay so all that this code
does for I equals 1 to 6 for J equals 1
to 6 it basically goes through this big
matrix and it grabs the first face for
each of those people the first face is
the one that has front on lighting
conditions ok and this is what it looks
like so these are all of the people 36
individuals you can see there's all
different types of people people's faces
okay and then similarly what I'm going
to show in this plot is I'm going to go
through all of the pictures for one
person and I'm gonna pull all of those
pictures and put that in an 8x8 array
because there's 64 different lighting
conditions for every person so again I'm
gonna create this big and by 8x8 array
of pictures and I'm just gonna load all
of the pictures for one of the persons
ok good so for every single one of those
images that I showed you of these people
here for every single one of these
people I have all of these these images
in all of these different lighting
conditions so this is really a massive
massive data set and what we're
hopefully going to learn from this using
the singular value decomposition is how
to go from this thirty two thousand
dimensional pixel representation to a
much lower dimensional representation in
terms of these eigen faces okay so
that's all coming up that'll be the next
video thank you